[Music]
on this sunday night a second evacuation
attempt in southern ukraine thwarted by
russian forces
a commercial airport is hit
and reports civilians are targeted
russia kill our our children our parents
while protests and arrests across russia
grow
americans take a stand i
would rather support ukraine in whatever
we can the vast majority say they're
willing to take a financial hit to help
while the u.s government considers two
strategic steps
refugee crisis
as the prime minister heads to europe
what will canada do to help and
ukrainian canadians roll up their
sleeves raising money there's something
soothing about it having the dough in
your hands and making it by pinching
pierogies
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us as
the russian army closes in on the
capital of ukraine we begin tonight with
a warning the footage we are about to
show you is disturbing panicked
civilians are trying to escape heavy
shelling in nearby cities but ukrainian
officials are saying russian soldiers
are targeting people trying to get out
this is the chaos that followed a blast
in the city of erpin a suburb of kiev
shells exploded near people attempting
to flee a new york times reporter who
witnessed the attack says at least three
members of a family were killed two of
them reportedly children
across ukraine tonight the situation for
civilians is critical in some regions
there's no escaping the violence david
aiken has our top story
this is urban a residential suburb of
the ukraine capital kiev under intense
attack
[Applause]
civilians grab what they can and flee
grandmothers in wheelchairs babes in
arms
independent media organizations say the
russian attack resulted in civilian
deaths
[Music]
meanwhile inside kiev ukrainian forces
build up their defensive positions
including installing anti-tank hedgehogs
far away from the front lines in the
central ukrainian city of venezia smoke
and flames after the civilian airport
there is destroyed
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
said it was hit by eight russian cruise
missiles
[Music]
in mariopol in the southeast russian
shells and rockets have been pounding
residential areas for nearly a week
for the second day in a row russian
officials promised a ceasefire to let
these buses evacuate civilians but for
the second day in a row the cease-fire
is broken mario paul's city council
blames the russians the russians with no
evidence blame ukrainian nationalists
those arriving in refugee camps at
ukraine's borders say all the more
reason for nato forces to enforce a
no-fly zone over ukraine we really want
that nato a close
close
[Music]
close sky
on ukraine because
russia kill our
our children our parents
and these are all scenes the kremlin
wants none of its citizens to see or
even know about more than 3 500 were
arrested sunday at protests across
russia they joined thousands of russian
scientists petitioning putin to stop
but independent media outlets have been
silenced foreign journalists threatened
with jail and social media sites are
blocked by a government pulling its
citizens behind a new digital iron
curtain
david akin global news
the city of la vie in western ukraine
has been spared from fighting so far
it's become a hub for refugees heading
west on their way to neighboring
countries like poland at the same time
it's also become a staging area for
supplies and weapons heading east into
the fighting our mike armstrong is in
lavee
sunday mass is something that happens
every week
these weeks it feels different
father pavlo droziak says looking out at
his parishioners he can tell they're
tired it's 11th day of war
all of us is so scared
because we don't know what does it mean
war
now we know
the people in saint george's cathedral
on this day have been dealing with air
raid sirens and checkpoints but so far
the actual fighting hasn't come here
yet
no one thinks it can't many think it
will
putin
this woman tells us what vladimir putin
is doing is terrible she asks how her
beautiful country can be destroyed
for the people who came to mass on this
date there was a message they were told
to do what they can to help
prayer alone isn't enough
we believe in god and also we believe in
our country
but we need to do something
believe without doing it's nothing
this woman has been weaving camouflage
covers for hiding vehicles and says
everyone is mobilized she came to church
today she says not to pray for herself
but for everyone she knows
there is a pressure in this city almost
an extra emotional weight there's worry
about what might come and worry about
friends and family in other parts of the
country they're also families that have
been split up
somebody that's assumed this woman tells
us she sent her children to poland while
this couple left their home on the first
day of the war
when we
were exiting kiev we hear
bombs
but
not so comfortable feeling when you pack
just
one backpack
and you don't know where to go what to
do you just leave
now that cathedral we visited is going
to be doing something tomorrow they
haven't done since the second world war
father droziak told us they're going to
be taking down statues and artwork in
case there's bombing they're going to be
wrapping it and moving it into the
basement colleen
mike armstrong in la vie of ukraine
thanks mike the u.s and western allies
are promising to unleash another round
of punishing sanctions against russia
this week and the biden administration
is in talks with poland's government to
find a way to get fighter jets to
ukraine after nato refused to do that
and said no to a no-fly zone over
ukraine jennifer johnson has more
with forces battling on the ground
ukraine is begging the u.s and its
allies for more firepower in the sky now
the biden administration is negotiating
with poland to give ukraine its old
soviet-made mig fighter jets and replace
them with us-made f-16s we're talking uh
with our polish friends right now about
what we might be able to do to backfill
their needs if in fact they choose to
provide these fighter jets to to the
ukrainians lincoln visited moldova a
western leaning former soviet republic
pledging u.s aid as that small nation
bordering ukraine fears it could be
putin's next target
pressure is building across america and
in congress for the biden administration
to do more to destabilize russia this
weekend visa mastercard and paypal
stopped doing business in that country
the white house vows more sanctions
against russia are coming to dial up the
heat the ruble is worth less than a
penny right now
the russian central bank is is not
being not functioning
completely the stock market has been
closed a new poll shows 80 percent of
americans are also calling for the u.s
to stop buying russian oil despite gas
prices at their highest level in a
decade
i
would rather support ukraine in whatever
we can if that means gas prices hike up
like i would i would pay it but experts
warn the ripple effect of targeting
russian crude oil exports will be costly
anything that touches a truck commerce
deliveries groceries lumber going to the
store anything that is being shipped via
semi truck is eventually going to get
hit it's a price the majority of
americans say they are willing to pay to
try and help save ukraine
jennifer johnson global news washington
prime minister justin trudeau is
visiting a number of european countries
this week to discuss the situation in
ukraine and how allies can help abigail
beeman is traveling with the prime
minister abigail there are calls for
canada and other western allies to do
more what are you hearing
colleen the first stop is here in london
and according to a senior government
source it's less a question of will
canada do more to help ukraine but more
a question of what canada will do and
that's the goal of this trip figure out
what to do next to push back on russia
monday prime minister justin trudeau
sits down with british prime minister
boris johnson and dutch prime minister
mark ruden it's one of a series of
meetings johnson has planned with world
leaders this week trudeau's office says
the leaders will discuss building on
their coordinated response to russia's
unjustifiable military aggression but
government officials won't share exactly
what kind of proposals may be on the
table just that they're aiming for
maximum impact over the weekend the u.k
announced a six-point plan to tackle
russia and new legal measures to
sanction oligarchs head to parliament
monday russia meanwhile singled out the
uk in its condemnation of western
support for ukraine referring to
sanctions hysteria and promising tough
retaliatory measures last week canada
announced different sanctions against
russia nearly daily as well as aid for
ukraine the big question now is what
comes next and what will actually work
another important focus of this trip the
humanitarian crisis underway as more
than a million ukrainians flee that will
be top of mind during trudeau's time in
poland this week where hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians have crossed the
border as canada promises to make it
easier for ukrainians to reach our
country too colleen abigail beeman in
london abigail thank you
as abigail mentioned the u.n warns
europe is facing its fastest growing
refugee crisis since the second world
war and fears some four million people
may flee ukraine the unhcr says more
than one and a half million people have
left ukraine in the last 10 days the
humanitarian push to help is huge but as
redmond shannon reports with so many
people trying to get out neighboring
countries are asking for more help
amid the carefree smiles some frightened
glances too
these orphans arrive in western ukraine
after 24 hours on a train next up a bus
to poland for the orphanage director
it's unbearable
my heart is being torn apart i feel so
sorry for these children they are so
young the 215 children had been living
close to the nuclear power plant
attacked by russian troops on friday
i don't understand why the russian
people cannot believe that we are being
bombarded in the south women and
children cross the danube escaping to
romania with whatever they can carry
like our family was basically torn apart
because i had to leave my parents and my
husband at home a cold day but a warm
welcome into the european union no one
in ukraine expected this to happen we
were just minding our own business and
then suddenly all of this just like
avalanched
in contrast to the divisive syrian
refugee crisis the eu has quickly agreed
to temporarily give ukrainians full
rights to live and work in the bloc
exactly the type of western integration
vladimir putin doesn't want to see the
un is calling this the fastest growing
refugee crisis in europe since world war
ii if people stay here for a long period
of time there will have to be
other countries offering places to host
refugees even outside europe of the 1.5
million refugees so far more than half
are in poland other destinations include
hungary slovakia and the small and
relatively poor nation of moldova
moldova's president says her country
urgently needs help with the influx with
russian troops making advances the un
says it expects that number of 1.5
million to rise sharply in the coming
days
colleen
redmond shannon in london redmond thank
you
coming up growing calls for those
responsible for residential school
deaths to answer for their crimes
this month the northern alberta
community of capoeno first nation
revealed 169 potential unmarked graves
have been discovered near the site of
the former saint bernard indian
residential school just the latest in a
growing list of such sites the searches
and discoveries are a necessary step
towards uncovering the truth of canada's
painful past but what about
accountability some of these deaths were
criminal and there are growing calls for
those responsible to pay for the crimes
heather urex west reports
the first discoveries of unmarked graves
near residential school sites grabbed
the attention of the world but
indigenous communities knew there would
be more and there have been from 215 in
kamloops to 751 in kaosis 93 in williams
lake 54 in quiscos and this week
169 in cappueno as the number of
children found in graves continues to
climb
we see it was never about
erasing who we are
but eradicating us all together genocide
the alberta grave sites were found using
ground penetrating radar but archival
records support another chilling truth
some of the children who died here were
infants the question that used to arise
was well where do those babies come from
and you know like the survivors talked
about
the abuse the sexual abuse in those
schools each of these children was a
beloved part of a family
and no one has been held accountable for
their deaths even though over the years
survivors have recounted countless
criminal acts few people have faced
justice there needs to be
widespread investigations about
how these children died and the
circumstances around how they died but
then also who were the people who were
responsible for their deaths
unfortunately it often seems like until
there's actual proof within you know a
government or a church record it's as if
those stories you know
never happen it's why the national
center for truth and reconciliation
continues to call for the release of all
historical records related to not only
residential schools but indian hospitals
as well our little warriors
waited
to find them and now we will ensure
they rest in peace but for every painful
discovery so far indigenous community
members know there are more children
waiting to be found
heather urex west global news calgary
i had the new program designed to give
black canadian families a leg up to home
ownership
you're watching global national
a new program to help more black
families break into the housing market
has been launched in toronto the average
home ownership rate for black households
in canada is about 40 compared to the
overall rate of nearly 70 percent the
shared equity initiative is the first of
its kind in canada and as ann gaviola
reports if it's successful it'll expand
to other canadian cities
oh it would mean legacy
it would mean financial security it
would mean stability and it would mean
something to pass on to my children
rather than my bills regina magambo
dreams of homeownership the single
mother of three young children as a
small business owner her hair extension
and beauty product retail business was
hit by coveted restrictions reducing her
annual household income to 65 thousand
dollars she pre-qualified for a 600
thousand dollar mortgage but says that
isn't enough to afford a home for her
family in this ultra competitive market
you just never know what the cost of a
home is until after a bidding war
happens
the average selling price for a home in
the gta is now 1.3 million the black
north homeownership bridge program
brings together developers willing to
offer dedicated homes at a discount and
funding from charities and government
including 10 million from ottawa the
shared equity program provides support
towards a down payment and lower monthly
mortgage payments for 200 families with
young children to own a home in the gta
black north is currently accepting
applicants and in discussion with donors
our objective is to raise about 65
million dollars
and that will help us because we want to
create not only in the gta and greater
toronto area we want to take this
program right across canada the program
involves twin mortgages one from a
traditional lender a bank or a credit
union to be paid off in full first the
second loan is with black north to
bridge the affordability gap we are
building a different playbook at how to
address anti-black racism and we wanted
to build a program that was going to
create wealth and that was going to
create mobility for the black community
magambo says homeownership would be
transformational for her family for
generations to come it would create
opportunities for my children in the
future so that means the world to me it
lets me know that i wouldn't be working
in vain but that i would be working
towards something ann gaviola global
news toronto
up next pinching pierogies to help the
victims of war
in communities across the country
ukrainian canadians are coming together
to pinch pierogies or petohe as my
ukrainian mother taught me they're
making the food to raise money for
victims of war and as carolyn curry de
castillo tells us the humble pierogi has
a history of helping
[Music]
they sing a traditional ukrainian song
of resistance while preparing a food
that's nourished so many generations in
ukraine potatoes and usually with fried
onions
my favorites are though with the
sauerkraut those progress yeah
favorite oh yeah all time favorite but
we make them only for
usually christmas time volunteers at
assumption of the blessed virgin mary
church in calgary assembling thousands
of pierogies and selling them to raise
money for relief efforts making the
parochial is very soothing there's
something soothing about it having the
dough in your hands and making it
christine musienko is the daughter of
ukrainian immigrants every day she talks
to relatives who are now in bomb
shelters it's my
last phone call when i go to sleep it's
my first phone call when i wake up there
is a long tradition of ukrainian
canadians shaping pierogies to raise
money last year we had a fundraiser for
our church and we made over sixty
thousand dollars selling pierogies this
church was built from
women making pierogies we used to make
them every sunday oksana david not only
about her relatives who were enduring
this war but those who suffered the
horror of the 1930s in her homeland she
worries about possible shortages now in
the bread basket of europe and how
quickly a situation of food abundance
can change anywhere and i can't believe
that people in ukraine in a land that's
so rich and can feed in a whole europe
people could be starving like they were
starving
90 years ago when stalin was trying to
basically extinguish ukrainian people
[Music]
making a food that goes back centuries
allowing those in calgary helplessly
ringing their hands to put them to work
helping from afar carolyn curry de
castillo global news
[Applause]
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie
tonight we leave you with support and
solidarity for ukraine in sports and on
the streets
[Applause]
from montreal to toronto people across
canada rallied outside russian
consulates calling for peace
a lot of nods to the crisis in ukraine
and in vancouver major league soccer
fans watching the white caps waved
ukrainian flags while players wore
t-shirts with the words we stand with
ukraine during the warm-up thanks for
watching donna friesen will be back
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
the